hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar from startup to scale-up
creative solutions to modernize your lab
budget i am jennifer woods of labrutz
and i'll be your moderator for today's
event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labrutz and brought to you
by thermo fisher scientific
to learn more visit thermofisher.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to know welcome our speakers
travis hardman senior manager financial
services at thermo fisher scientific
jason hansen founder and ceo of bridge
diagnostics and dr richard shan
ceo of stellate biotherapeutics inc
founder of stellate dna and founder of
quintaro
biosciences travis you may now begin
your presentation
thanks so much jennifer and thanks again
you know good morning good afternoon to
everyone that has registered for today's
webinar we've got a lot of great content
and it's really exciting
you know we're just going to go ahead
and get you know roll up our sleeves and
get get a little uh relaxed here and
we're going to put up a couple of poll
questions just to kind of you know test
the waters to see what we have out there
this this great day so the first poll
question you're going to see on your
screen there is i've i've operational
funds to run my research
can i still get access to capital
equipment you know so this is a good
question as as the results start rolling
in here you know we're looking for a
real honest yes no answer
situation i know some of us are just
getting settled in
but uh this is a great way to think
about you know or set the table for
today's webinar we're gonna hear a lot
of great content so again let's go ahead
and access the the results it's simple
yes or no
a lot of great content already coming in
most of you realize um you know
you do have access to it and you just
maybe not know how to use it
so again you know as as we think through
today's presentations you know we're
gonna hear a lot of great content and
feedback from
from from the uh excuse me our
presenters but uh it does look like you
know we're gonna be able to address some
of these questions at a high level and
i'm really excited for the opportunity
to do that
the next one is did you know that thermo
fisher's scientific
his financial services
to get you that access to software
instruments and consumables
so this is a really unique industry
certainly obviously we're serving
science across many different market
segments but
you know here's a situation where we
have access to thermo fisher financial
services
and this is a great opportunity for us
to do those things so as those results
come in you know it's it's
remarkable to watch this this number as
i refresh the results to see it's a
pretty pretty good mix of 50 50 of
yes you know
we did know that or no we didn't you
know this is a great way when we start
to think about this of how we can
accelerate research in science how can
we accelerate equipment placements in
science how do we help you as a
researcher you know become published or
if you're a larger academic institution
or a larger clinical account
you know are are there ways that we can
go ahead and look at financial services
to help us get that technology
so great a good good mixed result so
this should be a really good you know
solid one-hour you know presentation of
what we're trying to to achieve
so you know all things considered uh you
know we'll go ahead and get right into
it
thanks again for all the engagement this
morning this afternoon in regards to
those poll questions let's keep that
energy and excitement up as we
transition through the agenda slide
again we're going to keep this as
focused as possible we've got a really
exciting agenda i'm going to give you a
broad scope about who i am
as a thermo fisher scientific employee
i'm going to give you a high level
overview of who is thermo fisher
financial services
we're going to talk about the benefits
of vendor financing which you're going
to find is going to be far different
than any commercial lending experience
you might have had in your experiences
with with equipment purchasing we're
going to hear from some colleagues and
they've got great stories to tell and
we'll transition to those in a moment
and then we're going to take a pause
we're going to walk through
some high-level programs and offerings
that are going to give you enough
information
to have those discussions within your
lab within your academic institution
within your core facility etc
to think about how we remove those
barriers to execution on capital goods
and capital equipment and we're going to
finish with a without again a high
energy q a and as we get through this
you know just keep thinking about how
does thermal fissure financial services
help you remove those barriers so
because science can't wait so again
let's just transition to who i am right
let's keep this informal and and have a
lot of fun right and i like the little
preface here that says the world's or
the greatest uncle we've ever seen
is within the world of thermo fisher
scientific
you know we see a lot of opportunity so
all of the commercial organization
they kind of filter their opportunities
over to financial services
and it's just always great to see and
just a little bit about myself right
graduated from lake erie college
married with two kids beautiful dog
beautiful wife
and again as a family we enjoy playing a
lot of golf we eat a lot of pizza but
the joys of being a dad right we're
involved in in hockey and in little
league so there's always something going
on
and we joined i joined thermo fisher
scientific back in 2009 which has given
me a great opportunity
to evolve our financial services
programs and our portfolios
for
the the company that we support
so enough about me let's talk about who
we are right thermo fisher financial
services they'll be after mentioned
throughout this presentation as tffs
right we are a dedicated in-house vendor
finance team that has experts in global
support across all functions and
divisions that we support so this goes
for obviously all of our life sciences
instrumentation as well through our
analytical instrumentations and beyond
so what do we offer right we offer
creative financial solutions
pretty broad i understand but we offer
very
sort of cookie cutter lease finance
options at least to own or at least to
buy from anywhere between 12 and 84
months
we can go a step further and talk about
some of the extended financing options
we do have that we'll hear about a
little bit later from some of our
colleagues that have uh volunteered to
give us their presentations today as
well so what does that mean you can make
payments over you know 90 to 180 days to
get the equipment and technology you
need today
we also have what's very very unique in
our market is a subscription program
so these are all inclusive agreements
that give you the capacity to build in a
one thermal opportunity to include all
your instruments
your services and your support
your iqo cues your validations
potentially even
salaries and lab build out so we'll talk
a little bit more about that later on in
the presentation
and one of my one of our more creative
programs is our bridge to budget type
offerings we all know we have capital
restrictions somewhere throughout the
line whether that means you need
equipment now but your fiscal budget
cycle doesn't start until maybe next
month
but we can't wait till next month we
need the equipment now
so we'll talk about that a little bit
more in depth as well but why why is
this what is what does this mean for you
as a customer at the end of the day
we're going to be providing you below
market interest rates we've got tax
incentives that we can talk to you about
and educate you on through section 179
we're that one-stop shop
that we again we can include all those
consumables the services
construction costs so we're providing
100 financing on anything that we can be
able to source to you whether that's via
our fisher channel partners or just
direct through our direct manufacturing
divisions
the process is very quick it's clean
and it's very seamless in terms of the
documentation and delivery everything is
digital right so we can talk about how
how fast that process is if you have
questions in regards to that and again
last but not least we have extensive
experience in working across segments
that could go for federal and state and
local governments it could be academic
it could be clinical and it could be a
startup biocheck these are all
markets that we can service and support
seamlessly
and we have those tools readily
available just upon
the simple question of how do you help
me
get the equipment i need
so again a little bit more in depth
about who we are right and why why
vendor financing versus maybe you have
an incumbent bank or maybe you have a an
existing relationship with a third party
or broker so we'll just take a quick
step through these right the industry
focus is very easy at the end of the day
thermo fisher financial services is
focused on life sciences and we have a
deep understanding of not only the
technology but the market
we know exactly kind of what's going on
in there because they're training our cl
our commercial teams on what's going on
in the market and we get pulled into
those conversations as well
where that lacks is with that incumbent
banker broker they're not going to know
our equipment they're not going to know
it's residual value they're not going to
have any idea of what is a consumable or
what is a validation or what is a
service
so having that lack of expertise in the
end market again pushes the remote
fisher financial services into that
echelon of we're really here to help you
flexibility
right when we look at those incumbent
banks or brokers they're going to have
limited
you know scope on anything outside of
equipment
where us within financial services
again as we just mentioned we can offer
100 financing so you as an organization
can include warranty
consumables training validation services
where those aren't actual tangible goods
we will absolutely provide financing on
that where that again that incumbent
bank may not want or have any appetite
on something that they can't physically
perhaps repossess or actually put their
hands on
interest rates right this is probably
one of the most commonly asked questions
we get
we have very competitive interest rates
subprime in many cases because we as a
company are measured on revenue right
we're a public company and again
measured on revenue which allows for us
to get very aggressive on interest rates
when you look at a bank or a broker
right they're either paying they have to
pay broker fees so you absorb those
costs
and if you think about it from a bank
perspective their market rates so and
they're measured on profitability
so there's always going to be an
inherent hedge that they've got cover
where we as a company we do not so that
again is one of those
things where we can help you get this
technology as low as a cost as possible
the credit process
another one we get all the time
when you think about banks or a broker
or if you've ever gone through the
laborious effort of financing a house
the process can be long it can be time
consuming it can take sometimes weeks if
not months
when we look at it through the financial
services umbrella it's very fast it's
efficient as we talked about digital and
these are these are decisions that are
turned around in 24 to 48 hours
so from the time the application hits
our inbox from the time you get an
answer you know it could be as fast as
24 to 48 hours
so coming back to the science can't wait
aspect and you needing technology now
these processes are designed to ensure
that we get you have technology as fast
as possible and as we talked about
documentation right
with a bank you know it could be
extensive
it could be rigorous they might be
looking for pledges against real
property or something that's just not
needed
where with us here at financial services
the documentation again is all digital
in both u.s and canada
and our and in the process is very clean
and simple because we're collateralized
on these transactions because again it
is self-manufactured product
so keep these things in mind as we think
through
uh some of the conversations we hear
with with our
partners that are going to come on and
and give presentations and they're going
to tell us about their strategy and how
they were able to leverage these these
offerings within their business to not
only scale up
but also become revenue generating much
faster
so with that
i'd like to introduce
our first speaker of the day
mr jason hanson who is the founder and
ceo of bridge diagnostics jason's got a
wonderful story about how he was in able
to leverage these creative financial
solutions both on the equipment
perspective and on a consumable
perspective to make sure he became as
efficient as possible with british
diagnostics i've gotten to know jason
over the last 18 months
and we'll let jason get going here so
again any questions please put those in
the chat box
and we'll get to those right after
jason's presentation jason over to you
uh as we said my name is jason hanson
i'm the founder and ceo of bridge
diagnostics
happy to be here today talking about
thermo fisher financial services they've
been a great partner for us through this
journey
of about almost 18 months now and
looking forward to again telling a
little bit about our story and really
how thermo fisher
financial services has really helped us
grow and been a great partner through
this process
a little bit about bridge diagnostics
we're a national molecular laboratory
focused on infectious disease within
women's health founded in april of 2020
with the unique mission of bridging the
gap between diagnostics and therapeutics
to improve
asian outcomes we're headquartered here
at the uci research park here in irvine
california we have just over 100
employees and are processing about 300
000 cases annually
we're dedicated to integrity innovation
quality rapid turnaround time and
delivering i.t solutions
to lower costs and improved patient
outcomes
uh the the vision of the company really
i try to reiterate this to the team
almost on a weekly basis it's a daily
basis uh it's really to focus on our two
corporate values integrity and
innovation uh to separate ourselves from
the competition in the marketplace uh we
need to continue to execute on critical
products and projects that allow bridge
to grow market share by providing
services that are cheaper better faster
than our competitors and to continue to
grow the company in a scalable nimble
and diversified manner to ensure that we
can thrive in any market conditions and
whether any industry challenges
for those of you in the industry
you know those are omnipresent
so some of our core principles that i
talked about again if we really focus on
integrity and innovation and some of
those broken down as you can see on this
slide as far as integrity obviously
commitment to quality we don't cut
corners in our method validations or and
never deliver a test before we feel it's
ready and it has you know
made it through our quality assurance
team
uh dedication to compliance something
we're very very serious about in
particular me is the one who is the
person that will get in trouble if we
violate any uh any of those compliant uh
or any of the the challenges oftentimes
you know present ourselves in the in the
industry we really
ensure that everything we're doing
whether it be uh at the lab or or in the
field is
with compliance in mind in the highest
standards possible
uh integrity of clinical data is
obviously very important that goes
alongside with the robust method
validation platform we use
and of course devotion to corporate
responsibility
and then regards to innovation you know
uh cutting edge laboratory technology
we're a fully automated lab here we
leverage uh automation and software very
heavily to again
improve quality reduce turnaround time
and
just you know allow us to really scale
without losing again whether it be
quality turnaround time or just overall
performance of the lab
we've got a few proprietary uh novel
test methodologies that we're proud of
population health management tools
that we feel uh bring a lot of value
to our clients and advanced solutions
for improved practice workflows we
believe uh heavily in that as well
understanding what our our client
workflows are and working within them to
make sure we're
an integrated partner uh with our
clients
our value proposition uh pretty
self-explanatory and probably not too
dissimilar to what most laboratories
promote
whether it be turnaround time
competitive pricing uh partner and
innovation uh involving that is
certainly ait integrations uh we are
building out our test menu to build a
full
suite within women's health uh for
infectious disease testing and and as
you'll see from that leave our next
slide here we've got a strong leadership
team that uh really uh provides a lot of
expertise and and uh really helps uh you
know drive what we do here at bridge
diagnostics
uh missing tim's picture he did get that
added but you'll see the other folks
here we've got uh dr louis who's got
over 40 years experience he's also our
medical director and uh laboratory
director and board member uh
investor actually so uh he's a critical
piece of the puzzle uh along with tim
and martin and
khan and dr verma and r d
and then beyond that you know our sales
leadership uh our financial
team and then revenue cycle management
and as i mentioned the importance of
compliance uh and then of course uh
human resources
so proud of the team we've assembled
here at bridge uh the aforementioned
board with dr louis
uh vicki defrancesco who is the former
ceo of pathology inc a company that dr
lilly founded
bob whalen bob was the ceo of unilab
when they sold the quest for 900 plus
million dollars about uh almost 20 years
ago and then greg ackerman who was the
cto at uci
uh medical center and and just a
fantastic
board member and
close friend in fact so proud of the
team we've assembled there as well
so how does this uh this presentation
circle back to really what um you know
thermal fisher scientific can deliver
for at least they've delivered for us
and i'm sure for for your organization
uh really stays rooted in this staying
competitive in the marketplace you know
we talked about uh things like being
agile and adaptable and you know
leveraging technology to to do that
uh we always talk about people and
processes
uh you know you have to have the right
people uh on board and you have to have
those uh people make sure that we have
really robust processes in place
and then make sure the key thing here is
that again we segue into talking more
about thermal fissure financial services
is really making sure the resources
have uh the cut the team has the
resources necessary to execute the
company's
vision
uh i saw this in uh in my reading a few
months ago and i've actually saved it to
my
desktop i i look at it probably once a
month if not more often than that but
the role of the ceo uh you know three
ceo only does three things uh if you
really want to break it down it sets the
overall vision for the for the company
or he or she does
uh
communicates to all stakeholders
recruits and hires and retains the
very best talent that's the people of
the people it processes and then three
again segwaying to more of the
discussion on thermal fissure financial
services
make sure there's always enough cash in
the bank
so
right into the next slide here why
thermo fisher financial services well
really of that third
key role of ceo this really uh the team
at thermal fisher financial services can
really help and they have in my opinion
a very distinct advantage over general
equipment finance there's no shortage of
you know financial options for companies
like bridge diagnostics but why do we
oftentimes choose them or generally
choose them there's our partner um
really they you know i think given their
their understanding of the marketplace
and of course their strategic alliance
with the thermo fisher group that uh
that obviously sells
everything from
from equipment to reagents to us and
everything in between you know they've
got that distinct advantage they really
understand the marketplace and they've
got that uh you know obviously a very
in-depth knowledge of the actual
equipment and even consumables that are
being financed so that's a big advantage
i think they have in the marketplace
and what does that allow them to do i
think it allows them to provide more
competitive rates more flexible terms
and probably most importantly number
three
is the speed of ease of transactions
i've you know i've financed equipment
through other third party vendors it's
never as quick as it is with thermal
fissure scientific and i think we're
finding thermal fish or finished
services and i think the reason again
probably for that i'm not going to speak
for them
but it probably has a lot to do with
their in-depth knowledge of the industry
and of course their association with the
manufacturer
so bridge diagnostics use cases uh again
preserving cash uh
by leveraging in terms of minimal down
payment on equipment purchases even as a
young company that's a big deal too as a
young company it's often challenging to
get uh financing right because you don't
have a track record uh i was fortunate
this is my second company i've started
so i had a little bit uh you know more
experience than maybe a typical a
startup company or a startup engineer or
a startup entrepreneur i'm sorry uh you
know in launching a venture but but
nonetheless we were a very young company
when thermal fisher financial is
financing uh many of our purchases
and uh again it really helped especially
with the down payment in regards to
uh preserving cash uh even uh short-term
uh soft cost financing which is also
beneficial especially i mean with cobit
in particular where you know the volume
was
was uh much more it was much greater
than we had forecasted so you know we
kind of got a curveball thrown at us
based on the market opportunity want to
take advantage of it and therefore
needed to not only just finance
some of our uh
capex but also our soft costs and
consumables and thermal fissure
financials stood uh stepped up to the
plate and helped us there as well which
was a great benefit to bridge
and then even refinancing some of those
cost cut contracts because we were as a
new company so you can imagine um
sometimes it can be challenging getting
uh credentialed uh expeditiously
especially with coven with many of the
payers so there was a bit of a drag on
on our revenue cycle management uh and
then of course inventory management was
also challenging because the swings wild
swings of volume uh particularly with
kobit where during the holidays we were
doing four or five thousand tests a day
and then it dropped to a thousand a day
and just trying to manage uh you know
the uh the swings in in demand and again
thermal fissure
really helped us uh
uh navigate that and really smooth out
those right those bumps if you will and
that was uh again very beneficial to us
in the company and uh
and uh is really um just you know again
thermal fissure financial was a great
partner
in that regard so
that uh is my short and sweet
presentation um i don't know this point
is where we open it up to questions and
answers but uh
again uh please make any comments in the
in the chat and i'd be happy to answer
any questions as well
jason what an incredible story the the
more the more i i kind of listen through
that there's so many little nuances that
jump off the page that any startup
company doesn't matter the market should
really kind of take note of uh really
number three of being a ceo is making
sure there's cash in the bank i mean i
poke fun at that but in reality you know
being nimble i think about you know when
we first come together in being a
startup company and everything that
happened in between right so you came to
market as an infectious infectious
disease customer
or client
covet happens so you need to pivot there
right and then obviously you've got cash
flow headwinds because you've got to go
this way that way so so many
so many things that are in there so i
encourage anybody that's out there
that's in startup mode that is concerned
about going and being
able to pivot in certain directions you
know certainly reach out to jason and
have those conversations a couple other
things real quick before we jump right
into the questions that keep coming in
so thanks for those questions so keep
them coming in that q a box
he mentioned being able to to go through
short-term financing in a situation
where he is a startup so that's really
you know a value proposition that
financial services is prepared for which
again you know any banker broker is not
going to be able to kind of touch that
space without some sort of high level
end of security
so just picking off uh one of these
questions right off the bat jason uh you
know you had mentioned again the
importance of cash preservation and
being that startup company
can you can you talk about the
importance of it with regards to bridge
diagnostics
and how that helps you with your
timeline and growth to scale
sure no it's a great question and uh you
know absolutely when you look at all the
various uh whether it be departments or
just a general strategy that you're
trying to
to deploy uh you know they require cash
and uh and if you really want to grow
and scale your company you're going to
need
you know as much cash as you can
reasonably
at least if you're talking debt uh raise
without putting yourself in in uh over
leveraging yourself so just being able
to you know cash does a lot of things
allows you invest in sales r d
um operations of course and it also
allows you uh to invest in growth in in
all those individual apartments across
the company so it you know anytime you
have a a way to to raise uh non-dilutive
capital uh and as i mentioned in the in
the slide presentation there in a very
fast and convenient and
just really easy to navigate banner uh
like like working through thermal
fissure
uh you're going to take advantage of you
think of going to like the well
certainly the equity markets where
you're talking dilutive capital but even
the debt capital markets uh well for one
as a startup you're going to have a
challenge unless your private equity
back raising
any kind of significant debt and then
you look at what you have to do to raise
that
that uh that non-diluted capital you
have to you know maybe hire an
investment banker you have to put
together a
confidential
information or investment memorandum and
then you have to go through interviews
with different banks and it's a long
arduous
time-consuming and resource-draining
process or you can just email their
picture and say hey i've got some needs
here i'd like to finance some equipment
or even some consumables and within 24
48 hours we're signing docusign
documents and we've got our capital
needs handled so
it's just a very convenient what's your
point earlier in the call at reasonable
rates so it's just a
cheaper better faster
way of
you know meeting our uh our capital
goals and needs and uh again we really
appreciated the partnership for that
reason yeah
yeah wonderful comments i you know i
think about that as well right
you're in a situation where you know
working capital you need it you know to
scale up and grow so
no sense to dilute capital when you
don't have to
um in that same regard right so again
you
the design was come to market as an
infectious disease
entity but uh obviously we had you had a
situation there where you did have to
pivot you know obviously based on a
market need
so can you talk about how you were able
to do that and why you were able to do
that by leveraging financial services
sure yeah just in general you know we've
sort of built our organization to be
very agile very nimble
we're very big on iterative improvements
i think the mistake a lot of companies
make is they try to
they let perfection get in the way of
progress right so when you do that you
you tend to take longer to deploy
uh products or services and and instead
of we like to get out a minimal viable
product right and make sure we don't cut
any corners or make sure that mvp is is
something that is you know robust and
high quality but maybe not with all the
bells and whistles out of the gate so we
can build upon that it's a very nimble
way to approach business so on top the
other insulate benefit to that is when
you are throwing a curveball like covid
or or any sort of disruption whether it
be a pandemic or
competing technology or you know a new
entrance in the market that you're
competing with that may have something
you know different that is that is
raising the interest of the of the
marketplace you're able to quickly uh
adapt or adjust uh or you what you
mentioned pivot
as needed so just in general you know we
try to keep a very agile nimble uh
you know environment here and then of
course to do that again to your point
you need to oftentimes need additional
capital requirements that you didn't
really think of uh because you weren't
uh
seeing a curveball like covet uh thrown
at you or whatever it might be
so that's uh yeah they all they all tie
in together and i think if your
organization is built in a
uh by whether it be an agile or lean or
whatever uh you know kind of
management
sort of uh structure you you deployed
which uh you know we're big in that or
anti-fragile we like to talk about uh
business and then i think it serves you
well regardless of what uh may be thrown
at you and allows you to pivot more
quickly and and uh of course
money and
access to capital always plays a part in
that
yeah no thanks for that jason it looks
like i
i got time for one more quick one here
right and this one's just really
uh a bit of a high level one but
i we got a question here that's just
talking about the credit approval
process
can you shed any light on being a
startup company and how may be easy it
would have been for you to kind of get
an approval like this to scale up both
in an equipment perspective and and
maybe in a soft cost perspective
sure yeah no that's one again one of the
reasons i appreciate working with
thermal fisher the the process is quite
streamlined i mean literally how uh we
do it is we realize okay we need to buy
you know some more equipment or some
more consumables uh i will send a
purchase order to thermo fisher along
with our updated financials and uh and
obviously now that we've done business
you know multiple times it's easier each
time if you're familiar with our
business you you see our balance sheet
once a month probably along with our p l
every month so it's just a very you know
seamless and integrated uh process at
this point first as i mentioned if
you're gonna kind of go out and start
from scratch uh to the whether it be the
debt capital markets or even the equity
markets it's a long
arduous slot and uh and it's again uh as
a startup even even more challenging
where again i think with thermo fisher's
unique position as as also providing the
equipment and the consumables they're
willing to kind of take a little more of
a gamble if you will on a on a
early stage company like bridge so
that's
you know again just another reason i
think it's been
a very uh i'll say easy but yeah you
know pretty seamless and painless
certainly uh process so
we certainly appreciate it
and hopefully that answers the question
tonight yeah great
all right thanks again jason let's let's
go ahead what we'll do is we'll
we'll we'll come back live at the end
with jason if we've got more questions
continue to pump those into
the the q a box
that's terrific
thanks again jason for that
wonderful presentation uh and again keep
the questions coming it's been great
dialogue so far and as we transition to
our next speaker
dr richard shan ceo and founder of steli
bio therapeutics founder of stella dna
founder of kintaro biosciences
incorporated i've had the privilege of
knowing richard since 2009 and we've
been helping him with his financing even
predating that to 2006.
richard's been a great
advocate of financial services
and also has another wonderful story to
tell about how he was able to scale
his businesses and pivot into different
technologies throughout his career in in
the industry so richard over to you
traverse for the great introduction and
thank you
thank you for the continued support from
sum official financial team
it's a really great pleasure to present
in this
webinar series so let me start off by
introducing our study team
next
so the study team in addition to me
also
also has hara wu
who lead a study um
biotherapeutics working on application
on therapeutic front and rohan suter who
lead our study dna team
working on
non-therapeutic applications
next
so
before studying
product i founded contour bioscience in
the san francisco barrier in 2006
and later on we we set up live in boston
2012
and
corrado in 2014 and dc era in 2016 and
last year we set up a lab in connecticut
in 2020
so currently quintara
is an integrated molecular biology
service company
and then we have service ranging from
single sequencing and ngs service
on the dna reading site
and all legal synthesis gene synthesis
cloning
dna protein purification on the
on the dn writing side
so study project was uh
conceived and incubated in qantara since
2016 on and off
and was seen off from
into study dna and study about
therapeutics in 2021
so the study dna working on
non-therapeutic application and study
about therapeutic working on therapeutic
applications
and study
always
in the position to helping others and
throughout the year we have
incubated several staff companies
from max interaction in 2011
ligos in 2013 novel me in 2014 and
lately a regenta in
in 20 countries
next slide
so
to study about therapeutics is
is the mission of cellular therapeutic
is using disruptive
technology to discover and
develop neural curated to
cell cell gene therapy
for the breast future of our patient and
family
so
our vision is using scalable manufacture
of
programmable dna payload
which we call data
for homogeneous direct homology direct
gene repair
is a key to unleash full potential of
gene editing
for
the development of
normal gene cell therapy
for
variety of human diseases such as cancer
and genetic disorder
so
we are using
patented technology on the use and the
manufacture of circular single stream
dna as a donor template for crispr media
genome targeting so basically for the
mission vision and
underlying technology was all developed
uh within quintara
so so next slide
is uh
so for
for companies like kuntara all studied
biotherapeutics
study dna so how we stay
in a competitive position is we focus on
people not only our customers but our
own people our our team members
so on the service side we focus on get
fast turnaround time and provide people
with integrated service
and we want to service
our customer locally and in the u.s we
don't want to
shaping the shipping the sample far
from them so we want to send
we want to work
along with them
so another aspect is for the service
we do we want to
more and more focus on automation and
computation for the
the most expensive aspect of running a
business a service business
is
its people so we want to save um
automating
tasks
with computer or with the liquid
handling system as much as we can
and the third part is we are a
technology-based company
we focus on technology who which can
provide
new service to our customers improving
existing workflow and of course we are
keeping our eye out on technology
lead
into new areas like what we do with
sally
project
next slide
is
why is some official financial service
help us so
what i can summarize summer fisher how
quintara have this to start quintaro
bioscience this is back in 2006 at that
time
we're using
a type our system now part of the
official family
so uh some official financing help us to
get our first steam sequencer
and during our grow office and some of
which will help us to
scale up
into locations like boston dc
connecticut and
and also help us to
vertically integrate our service from
the reading and the writing so we have
start from a simple
simple gain sequencing
single sequencing half into an
integrated molecular biology service
provider
and
on the third part is is to help us to
branch out into a new totally new era
like crispr technology genome editing
which is not in the
routine domain of quintara
so with summer fisher's
finance help we can get
equipment for cell biology enable us to
do this
genome targeting work
and
finally i want to
say something on summer official
financial service
so is the best financial service uh
for a service company like kuntara which
is focused on revenue generation
we don't have any external uh
founder and they basically serve us
as a ventral founder for quintara
and
thermofish also is
is a very good alternative funding
source for technology startups like
salad with summer fisher we as a founder
of study team we can preserve most of
the early value creation to ourselves
rather than
also tedious
vc financing route
and third is
you know summer fisher is a vendor-based
financial service
with thermal futures quality of their
product and service
and
it must simplify our start-up process
in the case of study about a study
product we need to venture into an area
we are not familiar with and we can rely
on some officials quality and
the brassness of
their product and service
and lastly some official work
uh
with us in a very flexible term
really listen to our need
and
and it can also help us
to finance
equipment
from the outside summer official family
so i will stop here and
[Music]
answer any questions you may have
richard what
again what a wonderful story uh thanks
again
not to make you feel old or anything but
in 2006 i just graduated college so
uh but
all joking aside you know i remember
when i first started with the company in
2009 you know i had a privilege to meet
you in the kantara team then to think
about where you're at today right you
know you started started in this espace
you know you're now kind of branched off
into kind of crispr gene editing you
know and all that's happened in the last
15 years so it's been it's been awesome
to watch and it's been a privilege to be
a part of
and again the kind words there have just
been you know are incredible right so
you know for the folks that are out
there listening you know being a startup
company it doesn't end
um you know once you kind of make your
first million and beyond it it's a
situation where we oftentimes grow
together
and we watch you blossom into into
tremendous and wonderful things you know
we saw kantara open up multiple
facilities in different cities and
states it's just been an absolute
privilege to watch
in the in the key message i hear there
is
you know
kantara and the team at richard even at
stella you know they didn't they didn't
go out and raise vc money they used
thermo fisher financial services to be
that kind of pivot point uh so that they
can keep all the equity in-house
supports to uh kind of diluting shares
so so richard you know just picking off
some of these questions right here you
know
one here is just to why why why why
you know
why financial services as opposed to
outside equity
uh thank you travis that's a very good
question and
frankly i really
think for quintara summer fisher is
really our best choice uh without
thermal fissure i mean this what i mean
is the old
uh apply biosystem without the wonder
finance
there will no quintara so
nobody will fund us back in 2006
for our first
sequencer and
i don't have any credentials
i put my uh house to the bank to get
some home equally low that's all i have
and uh
and the the summer official abi
pro trusted me and the basic lonely uh
sequencer to start this whole 15 years
journey i really appreciate the help and
and also uh get back to your question is
uh
with
uh we have been working with summer
fisher since 2006
and uh
recently we we kind of have this regular
uh
finance like
basic incorporate summer official
finance
financial service a part of our
operation
so each year we update like anywhere
between
three to six uh dna sequencers
and
and we also got a lot of uh other
equipment some are within some official
families some are from other companies
and that really help us to grow
the company while we do not need to put
all our cash
on this capital equipment
and we can save this equipment to pay
our people and
to pay them better i think now i think
every company um
except during this co-wait period where
how important uh the person are so
so
um
with
with with this finance we can shape our
resource to our people and put our
resource on develop process using
automation using computation to help our
people to
do the quality work but
less intense hands-on work so let the
robot computer pull is deal with those
tedious operations
and
lastly i think this summer official
finance also help us to uh
to deal with uh
crisis or do you deal with emergency
situations like what we're experiencing
during the call time so so way uh for
instance we built
rebuilt our san francisco br lab
within two months last year and with
help of summer fisher
and
all in all i deeply appreciate the
support from summer official finance for
all these years and uh
needless to say is uh you know
the the style is also a product
uh hub by several fisher basic summer
fish in in the standard product it
really help us to
venture into an area we are not very
familiar with with gene editing with the
cell biology
so
any specific question
you can ask me and i i would try to get
as much as uh
tell you as much as i can hopefully i
think some official kind of finance can
help
many people like me and
i really think this uh the company i can
i found i started you can also do the
same thing
yeah
richard that i i mean you you nailed
everything there right to recap there
you know you started kind of with that
dollar and a dream mentality and you
know now you've sort of built this mini
empire and the service industry and
obviously in crispr gene editing so it
along those lines right um
you know we do have a number of folks
that are probably in sort of that
startup mode in that biotech space
you know
what what best advice could you give
them
you know in terms of what's what's a
really good common best practice when
starting a business going to scale and
trying to think about leveraging you
know financial services what so what's
your best advice to a startup you know
in at least kind of the elevator pitch
of why use financial services as opposed
to uh
you know any anything else that might be
out there especially self vander or self
manufactured or vendor financing
uh
yeah i think uh travis that's a very
good question so
just tell
a little bit of my my own experience i i
feel like
for any stop especially like technology
startup companies the early phase is
you create value rapidly and
the time is very important
and to deliver the quality result in
timely manner is
is really is the value creation process
and
with the flexibility and easy to work
with like jason mentioned
with summer fisher finance you can
gather equipment
really
in short period of time
and get and also some official backup
their equipment with the training with
the quality
uh with the qualification all this
supporting service
so it's
enable the entrepreneur to quickly
generate quality results in timely
manner and then you can using this the
initial approval concept
data to
go out to reaching out to the vcs to get
the next visual funding but this you
already establish your foundation
the value foundation you preserve
mouse's early value creation
to yourself to the founders
now that's
incredible right um so let's keep that
in mind
and uh as as you have questions you know
certainly uh we'll we'll uh
in the interest of time what we're going
to do is what we're going to push
forward
again at the end we you know we'll we'll
be back for for a final quick q a but in
the interest of time richard uh we're
just going to push forward
thank you thank you travis
thanks again for that wonderful
presentation and again wonderful
question and answer session
you know richard being in that ce space
this is a great opportunity for those in
there that have additional questions
don't be afraid to follow up after this
presentation
you know to have those more discussions
and dialogues as we progress further so
just moving us along right so as we
mentioned earlier
today
we're just going to take a deeper dive
into the programs and availability that
are readily available for anyone and
everyone to take action on
so as we mentioned payment deferral and
bridge to budget type offerings again
the description is pretty
straightforward you can acquire this
instrumentation now
and make no payments for some future set
date typically it's between 30 and 90
days or whenever your fiscal budget
becomes available think of this as we
were vastly approaching
2022 scary to say that
but if you don't have any budget
remaining left in 2021
but it's available in 2022
let's have a discussion about how we can
leverage that payment deferral get that
transaction done today or in q4 for us
prior to 2022 becoming
uh your budget coming available for 2022
and we can have that discussion now
right so this is a great way even if
you're a researcher and you're waiting
on those grant funds
and those grant funds will be released
in 2022 we can have those discussions as
is to start as soon as today
about how we can get that equipment
placed in your facility
and get that taken care of
subscription services we touched on this
earlier this is this is a wonderful
program that can think through a one
contract solution that includes
everything instruments equipment service
consumables software support
it can even take it as far as
people in salary maybe it's a
bioinformaticist
these are all things that we can include
into one payment or one structure to you
as an organization that qualifies
again this qualifies as an operating
expense
again this is a service oriented
contract that does not hit your capital
budget again this is operational so it
does not read as a lease it does not
read as
uh something that you need to put on
your balance sheet this is something
that's off the balance sheet so if
you're a clinical type customer or if
you have a project that has a very fixed
and determined amount of run rate let's
have a discussion because this could
potentially be one of those solutions
that fits for you
very easy for you
to budget out and when you're writing
your business plan internally you know
exactly what your fixed cost is for the
next three years
again available now so let's let's pick
up those discussions as soon as this
presentation is over lastly one of my
favorite programs that has gained a lot
of traction in 2021 is our extended
terms agreement
all this is is a deferral type payment
where you're going to make a cash
payment anywhere from three to six
months down the road
think of it just like a a sign and drive
type event and you're going to make a
payment in three to six months and
you'll own the asset outright
this doesn't apply just to capital goods
this could apply to 100 consumables
so if you're looking to scale up
your inventory whether it's for covid or
whether it's for women's health or
whether it's first
ce reagents this is an opportunity for
you to take on those reagents now and
spread out that cost
maybe it's in in three payments or maybe
it's in six payments or maybe it's just
deferred over 90 days
this program is a great way to extend
cost of capital
it's a great way for you to think about
how you can quickly scale up
without ruining your working capital
that's in-house
right so think about if you're just
looking for shorter term structures or
you're just looking for something
short-term as an alternative solution
let's let's get on the phone immediately
and talk about how our extended terms
financing options can be available for
you readily available
for any global customers that are on
today's webinar please just reach out to
us at financial services at thermo.com
we again are a global function
we have in-country resources across the
world so let's have those discussions
feel free to get the hold of us and
we'll make sure we we get you in contact
with somebody immediately so we can pick
up those discussions
and as always let's just chat as early
as possible about any of our service
offerings any of our capital offerings
we're we're readily available to have a
discussion with you immediately so we
can think about how we can accelerate
your science immediately
so we're gonna again we're gonna move to
our question and answer session but
again we wanna thank you for your
participation in today's webinar
there are a lot of offers out there that
are readily available
for you to acquire whatever you need it
is today
again push all of your inquiries to
financial services at
thermo.com and we'll start picking off
some questions in the q a box
well all right you know we've we've come
you know a long way in just an hour i
mean there was a lot of content driven
obviously i want to thank jason and
richard for their through participation
in today's event there's a lot of great
detail there right so the the message
is is rather simple at the moment right
let's go ahead and reach out to your
thermo fisher scientific colleagues as
immediately as possible so we can have
those discussions
i we've probably only got about 60
seconds
left on the
kind of the timer here but i just want
to give
you know we'll pass it over to jason and
then richard and just kind of just
ask a broad question at the moment uh
you know it's really at this point it's
you know thinking through everything we
heard today about
conserving cash utilizing working
capital um you know in leveraging
financial services to the extent that
you can
at the end of the day
you know really the question up to to
you jason is what can we do
as in thermo fisher financial services
what can we do better
to start reaching out to some of these
startups more proactively any any
guidance to anything to that
yeah i don't know just you know how i
found you guys was through your your
sales channels right and they made the
introduction so that makes you know a
lot of sense in my mind and i would keep
keep going that route that
was an effective way to to connect with
us and um again appreciate the
partnership
yeah thanks jason yeah and over to you
richard same same question you know high
level financial services is a resource
that thermo fish is scientific is there
anything that you know we could be doing
a little bit better to make sure we're
reaching out to those startups out there
uh i i think uh because i i feel like
uh i got a lot of help from someone
and i think if your sales people can
present this financing is uh
is the option to customers that will
help a lot and in fact i really think
summer fisher can also have some kind of
incubator accelerator function to reach
out those people like
like me like star things from ground up
that means they have some other con
other folks they form companies they
have a lot of money they probably don't
need this but a lot of people like a
graduate student paul stack like the
young researchers they want to start a
company they need a lot of help from
some official finance
noted noted to the to the 10th degree
richard again jason richard thanks so
much i truly appreciate it i hope the
audience got the best engagement out of
this as possible you know this will be
available in in the
repository at lab roots so jennifer over
over to you to close us out
well thank you again travis jason and
richard for your time today and for your
important work we would also like to
thank labrus and our sponsor thermo
fisher scientific for underwriting
today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab roots will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time goodbye